at this year's Pebble Beach Concours
d'Elegance you could spot some of the
automotive world's most remarkable and
influential designs one of the most
beautiful cars ever made the 1955
mercedes-benz 300sl gullwing was also a
technological masterpiece boasting a
lightweight frame and glorious doors
there were more function than for
Mercedes couldn't cut into the new
tubular frame to fit conventional doors
without sacrificing stability so it
hinged the doors to swing up and step
out the 1973 carrera 2.7 RS was a fully
upgrade to take on the existing porsche
911 and could hit 60 miles per hour in
5.5 seconds more relevant to today's
sports cars is the introduction of the
ducktail spoiler another design born of
necessity it was added to keep the car
stable at the high speeds its engine
encouraged and it's still around today
not all design details serve a purpose
legendary designer harley earl wanted to
add a taste of battle to the 1953
cadillac eldorado and the result was
bumper guards made to look like
artillery shells they resembled
something else earning them the nickname
Dagmar bumpers after the famously
beautiful actress of the era after
spreading to brands like mercury buick
and lincoln the exclusive bumpers went
out of style at the end of the decade in
favor of less obviously unnecessary
design Flair this 1962 ferrari 250 was
made for designer nutshell burtoni the
man responsible for masterpieces like
the Lamborghini Miura and Countach the
shark nose front end was inspired by the
championship winning Ferrari 156 Formula
One race car the one-of-a-kind Ferrari
had other design cues borrowed from the
racing world including a Plexiglas bug
deflector and wide hood scoop the
interior was filled with expensive
features like leather seats and electric
windows setting an early standard
combination of performance and luxury